uh don okay obviously we're at the
jersey shore a lot of
landlords a lot of tenants come in the
summer but the cdc just told you donna
ah you can't collect rent cdc
yeah like who elected them that woman 12
minutes ago was a college professor
now she's telling people like me who are
not wealthy landowners
that we can't collect our rent well how
would the government like it if we turn
around and said well
the cdc said we don't have to pay our
taxes because of coving
how would they like that and in our
banks that we have mortgages i mean
we're they're hurting us we can't live
like this forever and not collect rent
and carry a tenant that's sitting home
collecting a check from the government
for a sizable amount every month
and just sitting in our property while
we get stuck holding the bill
it's a sentiment that is befuddling how
this concept hasn't gotten through
to the government there are ways to go
about accomplishing goals
but to ignore literally half the
landlord-tenant relationship and to step
into a private contract will as the
lawyer i know i mean this is a taking
it is it is a flat out taking and it's
unbelievable that it's happening a lot
more
great opinions coming up throughout the
course of the morning back to you all
right
that's exactly how i described it on the
latest episode of the will kane podcast
big in america
not big in korea where we talked about
it is it's a taking that the government
is confiscating property from landlords
by denying them the ability to collect
rent while still requiring
them to hold true to their mortgage and
their property taxes it's just
it makes no economic sense it makes no
moral sense and it doesn't make legal
sense and i think the body
administration knows that as well that
is exactly right they knew they couldn't
extend it they called on congress to do
it they knew congress wouldn't do it so
then they they found a way for the cdc
to extend it and continue it
how does the center for disease control
have the power to extend
rent moratoriums you know i'm sorry
actually
we i do think we check each other during
the commercial breaks are we going
insane are we going
how does the cdc have the power to do
this
how does the cdc making law i don't
understand